foreign
Roy to Jesus if Jesus comes back no and
he said listen we have a book New
Testament say I don't know this is
no but the New Testament is uh reporting
either what Jesus says
because why there's some stuff that we
cannot really trace my budget to say no
it's not no it's not it's that that was
for Jewish people no it's natural yeah
no no no no this is this is
like he has two faces if we do sometimes
we do sometimes
you know the people that try to kill
Jesus that's his ancestors
okay
you know we always say to you him going
back a long time
it's a business
come back alongside listen what we say
to you that when you look to the New
Testament like I said what language
Jesus spoke
do we have it
no
yeah
[Music]
but the point here is we cannot really
Trace bad words he said we don't know
you know we don't we don't likewise the
earliest manuscript of the Bible it's
like 100 years before G the gaps between
the writers and the the New Testament
you understand so what I would say to
you that if you really want to worship
God and follow Jesus that is an Islam
no in Christianity Christianity is it
was heavily influenced by pagans by the
Romans
you are a woman follow one not Jesus
follow what and if you want to be Jesus
follow what become a Muslim
you know Jesus never spoke English
in Greek
and you cannot even chase it back I'm
saying like we have English translation
but we can know which translation is
correct or not because we still have
emotions
that's not the criteria yes we don't we
don't have the criteria that's Allah
says
the only foreign
foreign
you know there's guesswork
what we say to you that if you are
really wonderful Jesus exactly stand
Jesus worship God
if you want to watch a lot does it is
on Friday and he saw people accept this
stuff
three people on Friday three people
you know two women well there were
nothing before they weren't they were
they were non-believable
Christian really yeah
is dying
many times Christianity is died in the
Western World remember truly the Western
world came to our country tried to force
Christianity on many countries the same
people have left Christianity
with no they know they come they came to
know Christianity doesn't make any sense
it doesn't make any sense that God
become a baby oh God had to commit
suicide because of the sin that he
created us with
because that's it
Allah create us as a pure maybe we are
innocent you know yes we got desires
after that but you know
anytime bro except the truth submit to
your creator
Slim
Allah
um
foreign
[Music]
on his flesh on his last days he prayed
to the father to save him yes and he was
heard
what it means
except because
and he was here because he was a river
in person
respect God and glorify God
yeah even there's other scriptures which
were not included in the New Testament
that they said Jesus was saved
Allah saved him honored him by saving
him and guessed the Jewish people at
that time and the pagans that just were
trying to kill him
there is no book around the world
to preserved like the Quran
notebook
we are not we are not in need
future
memorization
Muslim children
can write the Quran down for us
your Christians call us they can even
write one chapter from John
as a miracle and Allah
made it easy for us to memorize it
Allah you know I was like I told you in
every mosque there is a school of Quran
look he is an expert of Quran no one two
three four sit down 20 years decades
foreign
sick
associated with Allah
but even if you know it's a relationship
I'm gonna wash Allah alone without any
Partners but I'm Gonna Worship people
according to the Bible you sit upon his
guidance
because that Bible is not from God there
is some stuff yes it's true but it's
been corrupted if you want to worship
Allah according to Allah's teaching that
is in the Quran
Muhammad said if Moses was alive you
know Moses if Moses was alive there is
no no no no please there's nothing for
him there's a citizen if Moses alive
there's nothing except to follow me
that's what one of the owners Prophet
Muhammad that Jesus when he returns will
become his follower
but Muhammad
we're coming back as a prophet of God
Prophet Muhammad
sometimes
here is
Lam Islam is spreading around the world
us
as we Muslims are weak never forgive us
don't do nothing
come on man you know you know I always
use his brothers
and keep him firm Andrew taste oh he
said he said the only Revolution that is
the evil one
them
because it's so
discrete organizations who don't want to
destroy our human nature and they said
all the religion is standing against
them that's why I became Muslim
Christianity
oh there's the cushions here
Christians are leaving Christianity
the Jesus was here Michael Jackson
it just comes back and he sits guys he
thinks they're crazy
that's what they need for attention
they have to do that because right
that's how to get to get people's
attention because they words were not
affect people
you know I'm big we're people of the
book so it's not we're still monotheists
right no no no people they put meat
originally a book was given to you
Harmony
scripture you serve scripture but if you
mix it up with a fossil
why
yeah regrets out okay if you read the
Bible the Old Testament in Samuel Jesus
God said I greatly regrets for choosing
sword as the king I know I know who it
is
greatly regret for choosing Soul as a
killer because it will stand back for me
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
however God regrets
if you say God doesn't regret in the
Bible said God's regrets
that's one of the lies that's been
attribute to God you know I'm planning
to do a lecture inshallah comparing the
prophets in the bible and the prophets
and the same prophets
speaks highly of them and how the Bible
degrade them
that's why you know the Christians there
was three Gods but they know logically
doesn't make any sense they said no we
worship because then no naturally
logically rationally doesn't make any
sense intellectually
you know Islam there's no salvation
except Islam bro Muslims bear with this
says except Allah and Muhammad is the
last message of the servants Allah
when a man will not be surprised with a
woman
then what happened intercourse with a
man and when a woman will not suffice
with a man she will start looking for
another woman that's from the start of
the hour person mentioned that what's
happening now
so how a man existed 1400 years ago he
said this will become widespread the
flags are all over London
there's doubt
hello
um
right now
it is
coming here okay I'll see you later
okay so what I'm saying bro I'm saying
look it's from the signs of the hour so
the question how Prophet Muhammad knew
that
wow there were many Jews and Christians
around the Arab peninsula that knew this
as well you know you are show me wrong
doing well no no no no longer
specifically everyone doing is gonna
happen no no no no show me which rich
man and by the way if you show me
something Prophecy in the autism I'm
gonna reject it because I've been living
here from God generally speaking
you understand
we know Prophet Muhammad said it
understand
you can't see that right now
there's many many for example Prophet
Muhammad said he said he will take over
the midst of Egypt take care of his
people
what happened the Muslims took over
Egypt you will you will conquer Persia
and roma for Byzantine the Muslim did it
as many prophecies about you can see it
right now that's why Islam is not like
Christianity Christianity is based upon
dreams and Islam based upon proves
so what do you say about that so there's
a lot of testimonies about people
becoming Christian because they saw
Jesus in a dream what's your response as
a Muslim firstly I I tell you according
to the Bible that is not approved Jesus
said even a Satan will do miracles
so it could be Satan and that is in
Matthew 28 28 he said there will be many
false prophets after me and they'll have
the signs the Miracles
yeah but so him do they say same thing
that Satan the devil because if you are
the same guys how that Jesus look they
will tell you look like George Michael
that's not Jesus
yeah I spoke to one guy said oh Jesus
look he said blonde hair blue eyes I
said no no oh you saw what's his name
Eminem
with no Jesus brother Stone Cold Steve
Austin Jesus Jesus from Palestine bro he
was the last king and rosam told us he
was a light skin where they curly hair
so you know
so clearly did he see Jesus hey because
why some people they can say look even
if they say that this cool personal
experience subjective subjective because
why
I saw dreams about Islam but I'm not
going to tell you because of my dream
believe Islam is the truth because
that's my for me that's the beauty of
Islam that's the beauty of the Prophet
The Messengers The Prophet the messages
came way truths and evidences they
didn't come with
dreams meaning causation Revelation and
they have cut substantiate profiles they
didn't come with believable prophet of
God why I dream that's it yeah bye-bye
you know Christianity is like tourism
except he doesn't want to for the truth
yeah
I never see a good person in this park
Christian speaking to him atheist and he
said you know what yeah it makes sense
and never in my life
never how on the earth you tell me God
become a baby someone changes nothing
how imagine I take you to the hospital
today and I get a newborn baby
crying someone treated is not me I said
that's good do you accept that
the way except he came like that before
is gone
so he was good
in the body of Christ I don't think
Christians don't worship the Flesh of
keys they don't worship
ing speak with them
the honest person that's what I'm saying
when the Christians said to us no Jesus
is not the flesh oh it's called no that
go and get the Bible because the Bible
says the word became less not a spirit
became a flesh so that flesh was getting
tortured that was good
yeah
that's why we were like you know you
know the teaching of Islam just about
till he the Oneness of Allah look how
Allah described himself
except him
the ever living the one who's in charge
of everything
he does not sleep
no fatigue
now whatever is in the heaven and the
Earth and in between them belongs to him
understand
this is
your friend yeah yeah
last time
you know so what I'm saying to you no
one listens what my fancy is describe
himself in a perfect way
the Bible describe God God regrets
doesn't make any sense God he he was
worried because people spoke same
language and they were building Four
Towers doesn't make any sense God commit
suicide because he loves us he had to
kill himself because he created all the
sins doesn't make any sense bro
well utilize it sounds reasoning man
my question to you why Christianity is
dying
it's not dinosaurs
it's going away
that's true you know you know what he
said you know where you found it you
know where www.keepdreaming.com
that's a website
in Algeria there's a little bit anything
my little Christian
s like in Britain celebrities Christians
in Algeria right yeah yeah there's a few
of them
yeah you guys go way back you know yeah
that's one of the church fathers was uh
yeah no problem mommy before he was a
bacon it was I don't care well it's them
my forefather sounds
because if you want to go back to your
full father you should go back to who
Adam what was he Adam Christian
that's why we are here
Muslim way you see if you want to go
back to your forefather Jesus was a
Christian Adam had no clue about Jesus
exists
I put Adam aside Abraham Moses had no
clue who Jesus is I'm talking about as
God of course Moses did prophesies about
Jesus
I believe that the Muslim but I believe
in Prophet Muhammad too and more
understand bro
why church are empty
Arabia Friday the most awful who gets
Saudi in Britain the message are full
attraction
if a Philippine Islam growing down you
know
Filipino you know Filipino how
Christianity came to Philippines
by force
of course they're all Muslims
names
and they say Islam spread the spider
sword therefore the Portuguese
and you came and killed the Muslims and
forced them to become Christians then
the Christians have a gut the gods tell
us we spread Islam by Soul Christianity
was spread by Soul how Christianity came
to Africa by sword is
welcome to Nigeria and many countries
how we came to America how Christianity
came to America
the Caribbean huh
you say louder for the Caribbeans to
hear you tell them how Christianity came
to them
with flowers
[Music]
so every 250 million Native Americans
and Caribbeans were killed because
Machinery saw them you're Christians
they kill themselves
questions
they have a right to kill you where are
you if you come to my country and I kill
you I have a right to kill you so the
Native Americans
okay so so not if okay so I'm gonna
bring you a good place by killing your
Revenue your mother
[Music]
yeah
you justify slavery and the kill of
innocent people in America
what's that to do that I didn't know
that you like that bro I spoke to you
last time you're a good person what
happened to you
I wonder if you justify the killing of
innocent people in America in Canada go
to Australia
okay I'm a question to you he's known
Christianity who came to Australia
Canada America South America Caribbean
by slavery and killing and raping
those Muslims who sold the slaves two
Europeans no no that was the Muslims no
no let me help you it was the Muslims
who caused the World War II
in Britain and the Muslim history the
Muslims the Muslim countries a lot of
them were invaded by Europeans
that time
before before we go to Africa you try to
justify the killing of people in the
stand
before
we asked to do with it if they were in a
better place
[Laughter]
foreign
Christianity came to you America
huh
with what slavery by the first vote that
departs from America to Africa was
called in Jesus
I'm coming instead of the Africans to
force them
to understand huh
study I mean you know history
you know to lie to us I Christopher
Columbus he would go to India and he
discovered America biggest life and Miss
Rudy it was a historian by the way in
him it was already mentioned and Miss
Rudy mentioned America way before
Columbus
was going to Indiana discovers America
how is good 500 years before how are we
going to discover something or do we
know exist
come on man
come on we know who speaks to fake
history
I'm not blaming you by the way but I'm
gonna show you 1948 with America and
France and Britain and Belgium they were
and the British and the Belgium they
were celebrating their victory over uh
Hitler at the same year the French will
commit him swear as genocide in Algeria
1948 in May
check out 1948
yes
1948 bro and and and Britain they will
kill other people other countries so how
have you are defending Jewish people
because they've been killed by Hitler
which is which is good I have the
oppressed one but at the same time you
keep Listen People in another place
I'm not blaming you by the way but I'm
showing you that look at the history of
these people you know
so anyway we watch the history
so my point here is let me bring you
back to Adam what was Adam Muslim he was
brother Lord Abraham was a Muslim
and usually
that's a solution
to Washington
so why would you become Muslims
it's about you you're gonna be in the
great house he's going to be integrate
by himself I'm Gonna Be In The Grave by
myself it's about you
oh
my God tell me okay someone asked you
why I Christianity
Jesus died for our sins remember I know
someone killed himself for his mother
what's that argument
someone kill himself or someone else
doesn't mean it's the truth
did you see if you when you ask Muslim
what is the truth can't give you a
thousands of proof time to approve what
is there with the truth
one of them in the Quran Allah mentioned
Allah will make Islam spread out even if
these Believers dislike it now we know
the fast Road Islam
with interest you know interest usually
will become widespread even if you're
not involved directly affect you but
therefore not if you open a bank account
your money's been used for interest how
a man that existed 1400 years ago who is
able to criticize about something not
randomly specifically detailed precisely
one of the Prophet Muhammad prophecies
huh
big brain
the sun the sun is hitting I mean the
sun is too much we don't go to Africa
because I don't kill you if the Sun is
hitting you too much don't go to
actually your own workout you know
you're gonna be so why are we say oh to
Philippines
I'm Philippines you're from Taiwan
coming up to you
[Laughter]
to you
we decided to shoot because we can prove
it Christianity you cannot prove it
that's why the law of Christians into in
Britain there's a study they do every 10
years and then yeah Christianity is
declining and Islam is inclining
Islam is inclined love
you know a lot of people revert to Islam
because the different motivations you
know they want to get married quick and
stuff brother you can get that without
Islam bro no no it's them if you want to
get married there's no responsibility
trust me
it's not a joke
just then and maybe but up to date not
like some people maybe we'll become
Muslim because Brotherhood
makes sense to him
no doubt I'm only dying denying that I
remember there's a a brother became
Muslim because you want to get married
as a Muslim woman
even he divorce the woman everything
stopping you from becoming
so who's
the best examples of mankind ever right
now
if I ask you how Jesus died with his
children because I'm not children so as
a man actually then G is not my example
if I want to know how to deal with my
wives Jesus never had wives how can I
deal with wives if I want to deal with
the people in the world Jesus never had
War I don't know how to do in the world
understand
what is the best way to to to to eat to
drinks do things Prophet Muhammad
explained all of that to us without it
degrading Jesus you know there is no
doubt he's on a high level
it's a messenger of Allah Mighty
messenger he's the Christ you know Mercy
stop but we're talking as the best
example that's why when Jesus returned
we'll follow Prophet Muhammad
married to women different ages and
that's the best example because why in
Taiwan in Algeria in Morocco in Nigeria
in St Lucia in Barbados you know
Caribbean Jamaica and other countries
they can marry different ages understand
so this age of marriage has to be 18.
that has nothing to do with Worldwide
that is a British culture it's not
British culture by the way because
British they used to get married is very
very young like for example Russia II he
got married Isabella when she was six
years old
historically speaking like in France in
Belgium but now they changed it why
because back in those days
you know about some people presenting
them present is a mean you try to judge
the people of the past by using the
criteria of our time
that's the wrong way
yeah you know for example
looking at the age of marriage how we
used to get married like for example I
cannot sell them Americans or the
British you're wrong why because
actually our culture is different that's
your culture
you can use your culture too if it's
from God yes
what is the criteria
to stand
you know in history we don't know about
no one in details like Prophet Muhammad
it's crazy
how we spoke to his family and what he
used to clean his teeth everything
his companions they were very uh what
they call it
not cautious the word
they were eager to teach us about the
small things let's learn about the big
things
what about the big things
foreign
you have
that's why we're here for to answer
questions if we know we know if we don't
know we don't know I don't know
everything
there's a few ex-muslims in this park
audio regards to them what do you say to
them I don't know firstly there's a guy
that's Muslim I spoke to him I asked him
I said if we love Islam will you weren't
educated he said yes
especially if you claim your practice
you understand but I'm gonna engage in
there something will leave Islam
like oh there's a guy he was a Christian
he said to me I left Islam and I'm a
Christian I said tell me why you left
Islam and make sure the reason you left
Islam is in the Bible
as a Muslim don't kill Muslim fight and
defend themselves and that's it but if
you talk about killing in the Bible say
kill babies and children woman
so why are you Christian you know about
Islam unit
do you know about Samuel do you know
about it
you know why
because they were they were pagans they
were washing how babies watch but they
don't understand
yeah it was God's way just purifying the
land you know like they didn't want to
raise any like uh children that belongs
to pagans there was God's way through
the Israelites
so that's what I'm saying people
of the pagans you cannot refuse them
us
yeah
foreign
[Music]
Haram
you understand
but in Christianity you allowed to get
children and across the Bible get babies
and children
so what I'm saying that I don't know
say again
It's Not Dead
it wasn't great to be honest that was
one of the reason but to be honest none
of you know the other reason
other reason in some you it's not
because of pagans the reason is you can
imagine that clearly he says God spoke
to Samuel
and some you said to sow God has anoint
you kick over his people Israel Israel
no he heard the voice of the Lord or the
words of the Lord go and attack Malachi
Malik the malachite Arabs
that's why the Zionist killing the
Muslims in Palestine so they're
following that yeah I think so yeah
because they said go to kill the
malachite right because the ambushed the
the abuse the the Jacob so this
malachite
the gap between them and and their
ancestors who did a crime to Jacob 400
years
imagine imagine now the Jewish people go
to German and they start killing the
German children and we say why are you
doing that I said it was a hit that I
used to keep our parents
he said no that's Injustice so imagine a
cup of 400 years
imagine going to say kill that baby
because something happened 400 years ago
come on man oh no I think I'm pretty
sure within 400 years the paganism was
still practiced they were still coming
back no they send a reason no it's not
because it's killing babies the reason
because the malachite ambushed Jacob
Jacob
either way you know the point is that
people complain about Muslims killing
what's up which they don't but in the
Bible no we don't care if it's needed
yeah of course
yeah we don't adjust it no doubt you
have clear in just commands to kill him
yes yes yeah yes and just D2 yeah glass
houses and Stones yeah the Christian day
they should notice for no even tissue oh
outside
yeah it doesn't make any sense bro
what other questions y'all
oh you're not born again no no you're
Catholic they believe you're not
Christian
yeah I know one of them believes that
Chris Islam
please you must he must do a lot of wine
he must have a lot of wine you know the
blood of Jesus that's right a lot of the
questions
a lot of the questions
so what are you doing with the church
business
in the church and fathers you know
playing with the children with the boys
anymore
like you see what happened in France
over 250 children there were tortured or
sexually abused by the the Christian
priests and the church there's a lot
there's a lot
I don't blame it a lot of Christians
of course
they take people's money unjustly not
even for God to forgive you you have to
expose yourself to the priest
is that in the Bible
the Bible tells you what to do please
and expose yourself to the police
Jesus came before the church yeah yes
okay
okay so the church
I agree with that 100 but the church
fathers yeah yes and now it's
Christianity
to be honest that the worst thing that
you come with him when you pray to Jesus
and Mary is the worst sin fair to God
alone
and remember I told you why is the
worst sin because
Allah how you say to Allah
exclusively for you but I believe we
should not have it let me give it to
human beings people
change the law okay
in the Bible God said to treat people
you are vegans
foreign
[Music]
Christianity without Old Testament
Islam
but if you take the Old Testament away
but there's a prophecy in the Old
Testament
it's not it's not not all way too much
Jesus name
thank you
[Music]
but it's not there's many passages in
the Bible in the New Testament we quote
as a prophecy which is not true
I'll give an example
the video about years back
[Music]
you know about isn't that
all right there's Matthew yeah it's
Matthew
uh
can you try to remember the code
so Matthew passes from the Old Testament
claiming that is for Jesus
you go back to the course itself it's
clearly speaking about something else
but
there's many many passages
but I forgot because I haven't revised
it
oh yeah
guys let me squatting
okay here we go
oh that's you yeah I made video about it
two years back a few years back so have
a revised there I want a chicken
it was Matthew
yeah
yeah let me go back
chapter 2 yeah yeah
Old Testament making a claim that is a
prophecy
what we said Passage
two uh
chapter two
Passage 15.
that's it what was it okay
that it must be fulfilled which the Lord
spoke by the prophets saying out of
Egypt I have caught my son so he's
making like a prophecy yeah okay where
is this position
you know what is it where is it yeah
where is it where is it no no no no okay
let me get Matthew he say look
here I'm gonna
so he's speaking about when even when
Jesus went to Egypt yeah and he's making
it as a prophecy
where's but he said but he's talking
about it
that's it so why is Miss Colton
[Music]
on behalf of that yeah
that's not that's not an example that I
made yeah so why Matthew if he was
inspired by God God goes wrong if he's
inspired by God he's lying so how can we
trust Matthew if he's clearly miscotting
what is in Hosea in Hosea clearly
speaking about Israel it's not promising
but if I cause emissions God took Israel
out of Egypt he said that as a prophecy
about Jesus to go to Egypt
it's referring to workers and exercises
that came out of Egypt and there was the
flight there was the flight of of the
Holy Family to Egypt because of Herod
killing the Holy Innocence right nice
Jesus about Jesus yeah about newborns we
fled away to Egypt the same as Joseph
certain years
no it's not it's not it's a prophecy
mean it's not a prophecy but Israel
to be fulfilled
so something is being said and it's
fulfilling it there was nothing said
something in the future rather I speak
in those people the Israel will go to
rebuke them enforce god making an
association between begotten son and the
sandwiches look he first is I don't know
it's not prophecy no try to justify it
no I just didn't get it before yeah but
no no even the Christians
he said it's a prophecy being fulfilled
but it's not prophecy because let us go
back to the original one or he doesn't
say prophecy it just says that it might
be fulfilled yeah
own that it might be fulfilled to wish
the Lord spoke by the prophet saying out
of Egypt it has nothing to do with Lord
speaking to the prophets nothing should
be fulfilled there God is the act of
this out of Egypt he's speaking about
something's happening now there's no
something's going to happen in the
future there's many many yeah you know
why
it's the name
uh his name Paul Paul
many many possible many so-called
prophecies in the New Testament when you
go back to Old Testament there's not
there that's why that's why one of the
Christian scholars in the earliest time
when he was debating with the Jewish
rabbi he said there's many prophecies
been mentioned but in our new testament
when we go about the Old Testament it's
not there what does that mean Old
Testament be corrupted as well or the
new system is lying
in the Quran is true that the Christians
and the Jews share the scripture
how a man exists 1 400 years ago he had
no access huh
you're gonna fight
the rights for the Bible
it's maybe I'll give you one example and
there's many
prophecy yeah you go back yeah
no I'll tell you what I try now let's go
back because it doesn't say that let me
go back to it's in Hosea yeah
thank you
not ever quite in the passage yet
11-1 yeah
watch this
go to uziah 11 1.
11-1
okay
yeah no it's from the Volcan
um
okay so the the Bible that we follow has
happened to his degree okay we're just
transliterating from the vulgaria which
is translated from the original
manuscripts there's an original
manuscripts
AC
after Christ
yeah that's an original because it's 382
is because 200 years between the
original writers and the the manuscript
anyway
like not everybody knows to read Hebrew
yeah
anyway go go to the okay let me do this
for people yeah
and the spirit of the Lord shall rest
upon him the spirit of wisdom okay what
was this
is
which one Isaiah
yeah
yeah okay okay and shall be four and the
root out of the roots of
Jesus the flowers are raised up his
roots and the spirit of the Lord shall
rest upon him the spirit of wisdom and
spirits of knowledge okay and he shall
be filled with the spirit of the fear of
the law should not judge according to
the side should judge before
where is
no no wait let me check again another
one because he's speaking about when
Israel when the Lord took Israel from
Egypt in Isaiah
Isaiah
yeah Isaiah
this Isaiah
foreign
because Israel was a child and I loved
him and I couldn't out of Egypt as they
called them they went away before they
face
way before their face they offered the
victim to balance and sacrifice Idols so
he had Israel they were sacrificing
about So speaking of Israel who's doing
even paganism he has nothing to do with
Jesus
no that's the best the foreign
as the morning passed so the king of
Israel passed away because Israel was a
child and I loved him and I cooled
myself out of Egypt as they called them
they went away before so he's speaking
of the Israel here yeah yeah it must be
like Jesus in The Gospel why can't
because
it's misquoting because the context is
speaking about the Israel who went out
of Egypt and established it's not a
prophecy no it's wrong but it's referred
to it doesn't say this yes it's just
saying that it's quoting a prophet let's
make a comparison between them
to be honest if it says so that that
statement can be fulfilled it implies
the statement is a yeah
it's not even their Christians so just
understand yeah clearly that is because
like he said to be fulfilled yeah it's
not saying that the prophecy might be
fulfilled they said that might be the
word of the prophet
field
yeah but those points of which is
poisoning that obviously might be
fulfilled
explicitly when he's actually talking
about prophecy and there's no talking
about prophecy okay
crossover between the New and Old
Testament right that's important
crossover the same way as the crossover
between Jesus and Joseph
was betrayed by his brothers foreign
it and but I know what I'm saying my
points here he says clearly in Matthew
that order in order to fulfill the the
word for the Lord that the prophet spoke
with out of Egypt there has nothing to
be fulfilled that word that what God
Said there in Hosea he's speaking
completely about Jesus so why Matthew is
using it for Jesus claiming that is a
prophecy being fulfilled that's what it
means for the word of the Prophet to be
fulfilled what it means
and then